أنا سحر لبيونسي ، فأنا أصنع لها 10
قطع وأقوم بعمل قطعة خاصة
لصخور اليوم كل ليلة أحب مشاهدة
مقطع فيديو موسيقى Rocky لأنني
أحب مشاهدة بضاعتي ، اسمي إيفا
يقول زوجي يقول لك  الاسم عبارة عن
إيفا فرعي في هذه المرحلة ، قد تتساءل
من هؤلاء في أسرع وقت ممكن ، وأين
ستذهب هذه القصة إلى الجحيم ، ربما
تسأل نفسك ما هي هذه القصة التي تدور
حول العدل بدرجة كافية
، فلنبدأ في البداية
هاجرت إيفا وعائلتها إلى جديد  يورك من ماكاو
في عام 1982 لم يكن الدخول في صناعة
المجوهرات أمرًا عقلانيًا بالنسبة لإيفا ،
فهي تأتي من سلسلة طويلة من صائغي المجوهرات ،
افتتحنا جولي الشهيرة
في عام 1988 في أكتوبر ، كان الأوساخ في نيويورك
صعبة ، ثم في يوم
من الأيام ابتسم الله الراب.  هي وأرسلتها
إلى قبيلة كابادونا وو تانغ ، إنه
أول مغني راب يأتي إلى متجرنا بعد
ذلك أرسل كل الأشخاص
وبدأنا في الحصول على الكثير من المشاهير
بام ترافيس سكوت
جادين سميث جوي بدس يدعو
باريس الشباب بخمسة أفلام Macklemore fa
يأتي الناس لأننا نفعل كل شيء في
الوقت المحدد ، ونعمل بشكل جيد بالنسبة لهم سريعًا
جدًا ولدينا مجموعة محددة لدينا 24
قيراطًا من الذهب والبلاتين والماس
الياقوت لدينا الفضة لدينا
كل شيء ولدينا شخصية جيدة
أنا لا أطلق النار عليهم مثل  الزبون الذي
أخذتهما مثل أطفالي ، لقد كان يومًا جيدًا
للعائلة والمجوهرات هي مرادف لإيفا
في الواقع في اليوم التالي بعد ولادة ابنها ،
عادت مباشرة إلى العمل
ولن أترك الوظيفة التي أنا هنا كل
يوم مجوهرات شهيرة  هو أكثر من مجرد
مجموع أجزائه البراقة ، إنه عائلة ،
إنه منزل ، وإما أن العميل الذي
اتصل بي هو نموذج الهدف الذي أمتلكه كثيرًا
وأعطاني ما قدموه لي
[موسيقى]